Dell has just updated their XPS 13 laptop,
so we figured we would compare it to a closely-priced
MacBook Pro, but unfortunately, for the second
year in a row, Apple has left the lower-end
13” model completely untouched, still packing
an old dual-core processor.
And this is really disappointing since the
XPS packs a quad-core processor and the MacBook
Pro is quite a bit more expensive for a similarly
specced model.
So we know that the Dell is gonna be a faster
machine for a cheaper price, but what if the
MacBook Pro will still give you a better overall
experience despite those downsides?
So much so that it’ll actually be worth
spending the extra cash?
For instance, the biggest factor in making
this decision is whether you like Windows
or macOS better.
Some people can’t stand Windows, so they’ll
gladly pay extra cash for a Mac, but for those
who don’t really mind either one, let’s
get started.
Last year’s XPS 13 featured Windows Hello,
which automatically logged you into your laptop
by using cameras to recognize your face.
It was great, but it required the cameras
to sit below the display, making for an unpleasant
camera angle.
Well this year, that feature is gone, so the
webcam goes back up above the display without
affecting the top bezel much at all.
The MacBook Pro clearly has larger bezels
that we wish Apple would slim down already,
but it still looks okay overall.
Technically, both displays are 13.3” large,
but it turns out that MacBook Pro’s display
actually has around 4 square inches more screen
space due to using a 16:10 aspect ratio instead
of 16:9, which is great for watching fullscreen
16:9 videos, but the downside is that you
don’t get as much vertical space while browsing
the web, which is a huge positive for the
MacBook.
Not only that, but the MacBook Pro gets a
2.5K resolution display compared to this XPS
which is packing 1080p, and the difference
is easily noticeable.
The XPS also has a 4K version but it’s a
few hundred dollars more expensive and more
comparable to the Touch Bar MacBook Pro.
We also tested screen brightness and the MacBook
definitely gets a lot brighter, which is really
nice for using in bright rooms or outside,
and it’s also much more color accurate,
with P3 wide-color gamut.
As for the design itself, the MacBook’s
shell is machined out of a solid block of
aluminum, so it feels great.
The XPS, on the other hand, uses a lot of
plastic sandwiched between an aluminum case,
and it’s also quite a bit thicker than the
MacBook Pro at their thickest points, but
slightly thinner at their thinnest points,
and when you stack them on top of each other,
it’s also quite a bit smaller.
For ports, the XPS features three gen-2 USB-C
ports, with two of them supporting Thunderbolt
3, alongside a headphone jack and a mini-SD
card slot.
The MacBook is limited to just two Thunderbolt
3 ports and a headphone jack, so the XPS wins
there.
They both use USB-C for charging, but the
XPS’s charging cable is built into the power
brick, so you can’t disconnect it and use
it for data transfer like you can with the
MacBook Pro.
Just like last year, the XPS is a bit tough
to open up since it lacks a notch in the front,
and the hinge has a lot of resistance, while
the MacBook Pro easily opens up with one finger.
The XPS’s power button doubles as a fingerprint
reader so you can conveniently login without
typing in the password like you have to do
on the MacBook, and the keyboard feels pretty
great with a lot of key travel.
The MacBook Pros keys are very clicky, which
I personally prefer, but it’s definitely
not as comfortable to type on with its low
key travel.
And perhaps the biggest downside for the MacBook
is that it uses the failure-prone butterfly
keyboard that’s been causing Apple a lot
of issues for recent years.
Now for the trackpads, the MacBook Pro has
the best trackpad out of any laptop ever,
and I’m not exaggerating.
It doesn’t actually move or click, it uses
force-touch technology to simulate clicks
using haptic feedback, so it’s extremely
reliable and you get an even clicking feel
all-around.
And you can even customize the force it takes
to register a click in the settings.
The XPS’s trackpad is much smaller so you
don’t get as much room to move around, and
it requires more pressure to click the higher
you get on the trackpad.
However, it’s pretty decent compared to
other Windows laptops.
For the webcams, neither look very great at
all, with the MacBook having a lot of visible
noise, which the XPS gives rid of using some
heavy noise reduction, but it also adds quite
a lot of saturation, making skin look a bit
orange.
But as you just heard in that clip, the microphone
quality on the Dell is horrible compared to
the MacBook.
And before we get into performance, let’s
compare the speaker quality.
As you’ve heard, the MacBook Pro blows the
XPS’s speakers out of the water.
There really is no comparison in everything
from volume to dynamic range and just overall
sound quality.
So far, the MacBook Pro is looking like the
champ in overall user experience, from the
design, build quality, trackpad, speakers
and display quality, even despite the subpar
keyboard.
However, the XPS packs a quad-core processor
while the MacBook only gets two cores, so
let’s get into performance, starting with
Geekbench 4’s multi-core test.
For some reason, the Dell is scoring barely
any faster than the MacBook, which isn’t
right at all.
It turns out that you have to click the battery
icon in the system tray and switch the battery
saving slider to best performance.
And you also have to plug in power cable to
unlock all of the performance.
Now we’re getting a much higher score that
completely destroys the MacBook Pro, but we’re
also gonna see less battery life than what
Dell rates it at.
We saw similar results in the more realistic
Cinebench R15 benchmark, where we got almost
100 more points by plugging it into power
and using best performance mode.
But either way, the XPS outperforms the MacBook
Pro by a massive margin.
And in Geekbench 4’s graphics test, the
XPS is once again scoring better than the
MacBook Pro, so we’re really impressed with
its performance.
But on a positive note, the MacBook Pro’s
SSD storage is quite a bit faster than the
Dells, which is useful for everything from
transferring data to opening apps.
But the Dell is the clear winner in overall
performance, so if you’re using professional
apps that can use that power, you should definitely
choose the Dell, but if you just need a powerful
laptop to do basic things like browsing the
internet, using web-based apps and basic stuff
like that, the MacBook will be more than powerful
enough.
But then again, if you’re not using professional
apps, you really don’t need the MacBook
Pro.
The better option is the 2018 MacBook Air.
It’s got newer technology with the T2 chip,
fingerprint reader, a more comfortable keyboard,
better battery life and a better price.
So in this case, who is this 2017 MacBook
Pro for?
Well, it’s for those who are using pro apps
that are exclusive to macOS.
But even in this case, I would seriously recommend
just paying $1800 for the 2019 MacBook Pro,
which just came out last month and has a quad-core
processor.
If
you need help choosing a laptop for your needs,
leave a comment below and we’ll help you
out.
If you liked this comparison, hit the like
button and click the circle above to get subscribed.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next video!